avec ma mère on allait voir une
conseillère d'orientation puis bah à la
fin les métiers qui sont sortis il y
avait marre un pêcheurs à faire maritime
et gendarmes de mer mais non je préfère
la pêche
[Musique]
toi tu fais une heure de route vers le
large au bout d'un moment il y a plus de
réseau tu es coupé du monde ça c'est
bien ça
dans tous les métiers la mer c'est
magique
salut c'est amour pour brut j'ai suivi
nail un apprenti pêcheur de 18 ans qui
vit près de Saint-Malo et qui vient de
passer son bac pro pêche je l'ai filmé
pendant plusieurs mois de ses épreuves
du bac jusqu'à ses premiers pas en tant
que matelot sur un bateau
je demande une escort jusqu'au port le
plus proche i Walker escort to the
resort
déjà moi en pêcheur du Ramadan donc ça
c'est réparer les filets avec une
aiguille
c'est la pointe de Brest de l'île Vierge
à la pointe de penmarche on est ici on
veut aller un peu plus haut on part
d'ici on trace des routes avec des
wimpoint des winpoints tournants donc
hop ça s'arrête ici du coup à partir
d'ici il faudra tourner et faire route
aux 50
j'ai rien compris j'ai rien compris
là je vais ranger préparer ma
convocation ma carte d'identité
salut Virginie ça va et toi
dernière épreuve faut que je me casse
d'ici
enfin est-ce que ce serait possible
d'ouvrir la salle de ramonage
merci
c'est des saletés là c'est là dedans
qu'on
courait partout nos trucs tous nos
morceaux de filets qu'on doit réparer
plus tard ça c'est un chalutier et puis
sur cap d'acier ça là c'est le plan d'un
chalut des gros pieux comme ça là puis
après bah ça c'est des ossières tous les
noeuds qu'on va apprendre tout ça à
faire et dommage que les profs soient
pas là c'est des c'est des spécimens
aussi ah ouais c'est bon sur 10 8 sur 10
lui c'est fils de marin pêcheur ça va
les gars
forcément les femmes peuvent très bien
se débrouiller là dedans il y en a qui
se déroulent très bien là-dedans
moi je préfère ne pas réviser c'est de
douter de son talent
un petit peu le chanteur
gazeks
monsieur toute l'année vous chantez dans
les couloirs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comme la Paimpolaise bonjour
tu as des cours généraux et tu as des
cours pratiques et théoriques et puis au
fur et à mesure des trois ans et tu
passes énormément de formation
protection contre le feu les voies d'eau
la piraterie
c'est simple c'est juste ça
la pêche et encore là-dedans
[Musique]
je sais pas comment on dit amoureuse
après à la côte ça va mais par contre au
large ça c'est un peu plus compliqué bah
vu que tu pars au large tu pars
longtemps donc
il y a la distance et puis bah le soir
c'est pas là pour faire à manger manger
avec tes gosses ou des trucs comme ça
avec ta femme et
oui oui
et oui et lui il veut pas de copine
voilà moi j'ai une moto c'est déjà pas
mal
du moment quoi
une préoccupation là c'est d'avoir le
bac
Grand Plage de Samuel
souvent seul mais voilà c'est un moment
ok fait pour être calme du coup ça me
convient très bien
un peu
là mais ça c'est les sardines qui se
font chasser par les maquereaux
ah bah vivre à la plage c'est un bonheur
ça c'est sûr être au contact des
poissons de la mer
je suis un pêcheur donc voilà forcément
les poissons j'aime bien voir toutes les
couleurs toutes les tailles toutes les
espèces tout ce qu'il y a tout tout tout
ça c'est pas trop ce qu'on cherche
parce que ça c'est pas très très bon
c'est de l'orphy de l'aiguillette
ça repart à la flotte
Perec c'est il y a des tailles et il y a
des fois il y a des nombres à respecter
si on pêche que les petits que les
petits que les petits bah à la fin il y
a plus de gros du coup sauf que tout
pêcheur ce qui cherche c'est le gros
poisson c'est le gros donc il m'a faut
laisser les petits tranquilles faut
qu'il se reproduisent
qui grandissent tout ça
on le pêchera quand il sera plus gros
ça c'est ce qu'on recherche ça c'est du
maquereau
depuis tout petit je suis passionné de
pêche mon père m'a transmis sa passion
de la pêche
de bord pêche de d'amateur pas de
professionnel non au début parce qu'on
habite plus dans les terres
et aujourd'hui au bord de la mer
c'était ça aussi qu'il a
aimé c'est pas le poisson de la mer il a
l'air d'avoir un pied marin parce que
maintenant il en est même plus qu'aux
j'ai dû commencer je devais avoir ouais
6 ans je pense 5-6 ans
comme moi ça m'a été transmis par mon
père lui si un jour j'ai un enfant bah
j'espère il pêchera avec moi
mon père il est électricien et ma mère
elle est commerciale
rien à voir du tout et ce sont séparés
ils habitaient dans la même ville mon
père voulait partir lui bah du coup il a
trouvé une maison au bord de la côte
ouais mon père il me soutient bien
direct et il m'a dit c'est un métier dur
mais bon je sais que tu kiffes les
poissons que tu kiffes la merde tout ça
bah c'est un métier qui te va bien j'ai
fait bah je me lance j'ai eu des bons
moments avec lui à la pêche et c'est lui
qui m'a emmené c'est lui qui m'apprend
plein de trucs plein de techniques donc
ouais je suis plus proche de mon père
parce que ma mère elle est un peu trop
carrée elle aime les trucs sont carrés
sauf que moi vu que j'aime bien être
libre bah ça colle pas trop à des
moments tu vois du coup elle a lâché
prise et ben elle m'a fait ce que vous
voulez maintenant écoute
c'est comme ça
[Musique]
moi
aussi en ce moment j'en fais un peu
beaucoup
si j'en ai fait la plus grosse que j'ai
fait c'est de 45 mais c'est des belles
mémère elles sont épaisses hein
on connaît un pêcheur
on m'appelle souvent
ça s'écrit
en Bretagne
on a vu un faisan c'est quoi ça
on a passé au lycée
voilà on en attente de les résultats
patates 15 heures
[Musique]
si moi je l'ai pas je donne pas cher de
ma classe
tout le monde est en stress là [ __ ]
ils sont où les résultats
je suis pas sûr un pêcheur c'est tout le
temps pas sûr
on attend on attend
je crois c'est bon je crois les ailes il
y a un mec sur le groupe il va envoyer
un truc je crois qu'on est quasiment
tous admis ouais moi j'ai un peu moi
j'ai mention de bien
voilà
tu as bossé pour aussi ouais
quand tu es passionné
et puis maintenant on a plus qu'à se
tracasser quand tu seras en mer quoi
voilà exactement
les résultats de tes examens maintenant
reste à casser quand tu seras là-bas
loin du bord quoi au large ils annoncent
un coup de tabac un coup de vent alors
est-ce qu'ils ont le temps de se mettre
à l'abri un abri s'ils sont dans la
Manche un abri
anglais un abri français quand tu es au
large et qui t'arrive une couille même
vu que c'est des gros engins de pêche
lourd ça bouge tout le temps à tout
moment tu peux te prendre un coup ton
mal tombé et après bah c'était mieux de
la merde donc les secours ils sont pas
là avant longtemps
bon la bienvenue dans le monde on va
rentrer dans la vie active
la prochaine fois on se reverra à bord
[Musique]
c'est ça que j'ai réussi dans le métier
c'est les vues là tu les as pas dans
tous les métiers
tu regardes autour de toi t'as que la
mer il y a rien c'est
tu te sens bien tu te sens bien quand tu
es là-bas
c'est super beau
pourquoi tu fais une heure de route vers
le large une ou deux heures tu captes
plus au bout d'un moment il y a plus de
réseau tu es coupé du monde ça c'est
bien ça
et ça c'est un truc que tu kiffes
de la société du monde
[Musique]
ça ça s'appelle une bûche et en bus les
coquilles
c'est pour les calibrer
[Musique]
j'ai une vie de famille bah je serai
sûrement à la côte mais si j'ai pas de
vie de famille je serai au large j'avais
bien kiffé partir loin
de la côte vu que là maintenant je suis
lancé là-dedans je me vois pas être dans
un autre truc
[Musique]
c'est la première fois que je retourne à
la pêche depuis la fin de mes études
il y en a à l'école mais il y en a pas
beaucoup qui font la pêche moi
d'accord
[Musique]
continue comme ça enfin là-dedans c'est
sûr
exactement c'est que le début
j'ai envie de voir du pays voyager
où le vent me mènera j'ai pas d'idée en
tête comme je vis au jour le jour j'irai
où le vent me mène